country music's our John Rich performed
at the outdoor festival just a short
while before the gunman opened fire he
joins us now from Los Angeles John thank
you so much for being with us tonight
and sharing which must have been just a
horrific evening and to have experienced
that and just the loss of life if you
can tell our viewers where you were when
this massacre started well you know we
played about 90 minutes to two hours
before Jason Aldean and so we had
actually loaded up our bus and there's a
little little country bar that I have in
Las Vegas that I own and we went over
there as big and rich and cowboy to play
a little after show set so we were over
there on stage there and and got the tap
on the shoulder that there was an active
shooter what they told us is they
thought there were multiple active
shooters and didn't know where they were
and so we immediately stopped playing
and got everybody away from the windows
and tried to secure the location I made
a phone call back to a friend of mine
who plays with Jason Aldean and couldn't
believe he actually answered the phone
but he did said they had just thrown him
and a bunch of the guys into pickup
trucks and were you know burning rubber
out of the parking lot trying to get
them out of there and that the bullets
were literally flying through the tour
buses through the instruments on stage
through the rigging he said he looked up
in the back of the pickup and all he saw
was bodies everywhere unbelievable how
much time passed because you bring up
such an important point there was a lot
of confusion with the hysteria and so
much gunfire going on where people were
calling in you know shots fired at a
number of different locations how long
was it so you were able to identify and
you found out that in fact it was at
just at the Mandalay Bay where you had
been it was probably two o'clock in the
morning Vegas time when we got word that
they had neutralized this shooter and
that they didn't think there were any
more but I can say you like my partner
Big Kenny he stepped off our tour bus as
a SWAT team was coming straight down the
street rifles aimed right at him he
throws his hands up and says hey guys
it's me and they said get back on the
bus I mean I got
c'est la LAPD and all the first
responders activated instantaneously on
this deal I mean I watched it happen in
real time it was it was nothing short of
impressive watching them move through
that town like that okay we're gonna
take it around the table again thank you
for being with us and Greg has a
question hey John when you were in that
bar were there any law enforcement
people there with you and and when you
heard the news did you guys do anything
because you're close so where things are
happening yeah yeah so in the bar that I
have we have a big emphasis on veterans
and active duty I have a lot of a lot of
police officers that come and hang out
there and so actually had a it was a
Minneapolis police officer off-duty was
in my bar hanging out and he came up to
me and he showed me his badge and he
says I'm officer I could forget his last
name but I'm an officer and I am not
armed for the first time ever I can't
believe it are you armed I said yes sir
I am armed I have my concealed weapons
permit and I said yes I am armed he goes
can I have your firearm so I can hold
point on this front door and so I handed
over my firearm to him
everybody got behind him and he for
about two hours without flinching this
guy kept a point on that front door just
in case somebody came through Wow Wow
what an incredible story that is a
really amazing story John I wanted to
ask you about the fact that these
festivals have become so popular
especially for country music I know
they're not the only ones that do it but
that country music singers to me are
some of the most accessible to their
fans you personally put yourselves out
there you feel very close to them and I
wondered if you would talk to Jason
Aldean or any of the other performers
about how they're feeling tonight and
that personal heartbreak that they feel
about what's happened well you're
exactly right you know country music is
really a unique genre I think because of
the relationship between the singers and
the fans you know we hang out with them
we talk to them we'll go have fun with
them or our concerts are very
interactive with our fans I mean I'm a
country music fan so I'm a fan of other
singers and and we all it's like a big
family out there
was one guy that I'm good friends with
named DJ silver if you go look him up
he's a great guy and he plays with Jason
Aldean that man this guy tells me that
his six month old son who I met before
the show and got a picture with his six
month old son and the nanny who was
watching him were in the room next door
to the shooter on the 32nd floor
literally in the room next door and he
went for about three or four hours and
didn't know where his son was I mean
just you look out and you see these
country music fans let me tell you
something these people were coming to
this show from Southern California from
Arizona Nevada they were from all over
the place about yeah Canada - during the
big and rich show every show we bring up
veterans and active-duty on stage and at
one point we had all 22,000 people at
that show with their iPhones up in the
air and the bright light on faced facing
the stage singing in unison god Bless
America in unison and I look at that and
I go there's no race in that there's no
politics in that there's no religion in
that that's just America with one voice
all singing a song about our country
celebrating the fact that we have the
freedom to have these big outdoor music
festivals and live our lives that was
literally going on about two hours
before this shooting started okay Jesse
hey John after you were on the main
stage and then you left to go to your
bar to perform for some of your fans
though all everything went down at that
point you must have had people there in
the bar that still knew people who were
at the main event how are they reacting
knowing it was going down I mean that
must have just been heartbreaking to
watch and to experience you're exactly
right because all the people that had
come over to our bar to watch us play
had just come from the concert I
remember this one lady in particular
she's Canadian
and she was just I mean uncontrollably
weeping in the room because she could
not contact her friends back at the show
and her husband came over to me and said
John would you mind coming over and
talking to my wife and trying to calm
her down
and so I said absolutely so I'm over
there with my arm around this this
Canadian
lady you know trying to try to calm her
down and get the situation to try to try
to be as calm as possible but let me
tell you that is a stretch to try to be
calm in that situation one aha John
so what struck me was the fan experience
because what we are hearing today is
that people thought oh my gosh it's just
firecrackers or some kind of noise
that's part of the show and they were
slow to understand I think Jason Aldean
had been on stage about 20 minutes that
said before this occurred had there been
fireworks had there been any kind of you
know show that would have had noise that
might have confused the people who were
there no one there hadn't anything like
that but these shows are huge I mean
they are really loud really bright
there's a lot going on and you know when
you when you hear that rat-a-tat-tat
tat-tat-tat you kind of see everybody
pause for a minute go what am i hearing
because you know you could think maybe
it is part of the show maybe it's maybe
it's pyrotechnics or something that's
going on but I think you know when you
hear that that level of gunfire you know
that's a fully automatic weapon going
off somewhere and it's it's not
surprising it took people a minute
because you're talking about a really
really big powerful show going on at
that point and do you think that it was
easy to get out it was a pretty wide
open space I mean it's this major open
lot out there and it's pretty easy yeah
it's it easy to get to get out more than
other places that we play it would be
easier than say perhaps a stadium like a
football stadium or something because it
was outdoors and pretty wide open thank
goodness but I mean that had so many
people crammed into one place that like
I said it's it's virtually impossible to
stay calm in that situation John in the
time we have remaining I just want to
point out that we talked about country
music fans but also country music that
you do a ton for all sorts of people I
know you're planning for a big benefit
that's to take place next month so that
you can help hurricane victims you're
always doing things for veterans for law
enforcement for people from all over and
so hopefully you guys can all feel the
from all of us back to you as well
absolutely and I can tell you this these
guys do stuff like this to try to keep
the rest of us from doing what we want
to do with our lives and that's not
going to happen and I would expect a
really strong response out of all of
country music as to what happened last
night you know we got it you got to pray
for these folks too you know people say
our thoughts and prayers you actually
need to pray you actually need to speak
to the Lord and say please bring some
comfort to these people because this is
beyond the pale what has happened and
thank you for your time tonight we
certainly appreciate it